the Sanders incident is just the latest
in a series of decorum busting moves
that would probably have been
unthinkable a generation or two ago over
the weekend California Democrat Maxine
Waters called on supporters to quote
push back on Trump cabinet members
spotted in restaurants stores or other
public places she's been getting
hammered for that
moments ago she held a news conference
on Capitol Hill to insist she never
called for any violence Trump is the one
who was creating lies trying to have
people believe that I talked about
harming people there's nowhere in my
statement anytime anyplace that we
talked about on and so our members of
the Democratic caucus are talking about
civility and that makes good sense
but protests in civility protest is
about peaceful resistance to the kind of
actions that we're experiencing from
this president again that moments ago on
Capitol Hill tonight correspondent Doug
mackelway looks at the rising tide of
anger and politics and weather and the
end is in sight in the window of the red
hen restaurant in Lexington Virginia the
words of Martin Luther King jr. are
framed quote love is the only force
capable of transforming an enemy into a
friend on Friday night the red hens of
owners Stephanie wilkinson asked White
House press secretary Sarah Sanders to
leave
citing Trump administration policies
Sanders complied
after an employee of the restaurant
posted about the incident Sanders
tweeted about wilkinson quote her
actions say far more about her than
about me wilkinson later told The
Washington Post quote I'm not a huge fan
of confrontation but she added this
feels like the moment in our democracy
when people have to make uncomfortable
actions for others the booting out of
Sanders set a new standard in incivility
this is very dangerous she should
apologize the American public it follows
a week in which members of the
Congressional Hispanic Caucus heckled
the president in the Capitol building
and a congressional intern hurled an
f-bomb and mr. Trump the same week
homeland security secretary Kirsten
Neilson was shouted out of a DC
restaurant by aggressive hecklers they
showed up outside her town home to
Florida Attorney General Pam Bondi had
to abandon her night out at the movies
in the face of a similarly
confrontational mob if she has people to
protest that's one thing but to continue
this their inciting violence that while
Democratic California congresswoman
Maxine Waters called on her supporters
to step up the confrontations quote if
you see anybody from that cabinet in a
restaurant in a department store at a
gasoline station you get out and you
create a crowd and you push back on them
and you tell them they're not welcome
anymore anywhere I obviously what Maxine
Waters said is beyond the pale and
really the next move is a democratic
colleagues if she starts to feel the
heat from Democrats in the house would
tell her publicly she went too far and
she should take it back that's how you
start to fix these things and that's
what the Senate Minority Leader did this
afternoon but no one should call for the
harassment of political opponents that's
not right that's not American House
Minority Leader Nancy Pelosi partly did
that not naming waters but naming the
president she tweeted quote Trump's
daily lack of civility has provoked
responses at a predictable but
unacceptable that counter-puncher in
chief fired back with this tweet
congresswoman Maxine Waters an
extraordinarily low IQ person has become
together with Nancy Pelosi the face of
the Democrat Party
she has just called for harm to
supporters be careful what you wish for
max and you saw on that late afternoon
press conference just moments ago how
Maxine Waters blame the president for
the violent rhetoric it took no
responsibility for itself it would be
reasonable to infer however that she was
forced into that late afternoon press
conference by the tweet from leader
Pelosi on the house side and the floret
remarks by Senator Schumer on the Senate
side that's it from Lexington bretton
back to you Kel way outside the red
hand-dug thanks